every few months it seems there's
another study or survey showing that
Americans are increasingly depressed and
anxious and lonely I think we all kind
of get the point by now we all
understand that and the important
question is why
okay why are we such a depressed anxious
lonely culture and the next most
important question once you've answered
those is uh what can we do about it
nothing this is where most commentary on
the subject seems to fail the media will
publish study results they'll do TV
segments about it they'll bring in a TV
Doctor to opine for a few minutes about
the fact that everyone's depressed and
that'll be it there's never any serious
attempt to Grapple with the why like why
is this happening what is going on